When in doubt, hit 'em with a twist.
That seems to have been the thought process
of Avengers: Endgame screenwriters Christopher
Markus and Stephen McFeely, who recently sat
down with the New York Times to discuss the
film's plot in the wake of its runaway success.
The twist in question occurs early in the
film, when the remaining Avengers track down
Thanos, now living on the lonely planet he
retreated to after snuffing out half of all
life in the universe.
Their goal: to swipe the Infinity Stones and
use them to undo the Mad Titan's damage.
But upon arriving, they find that Thanos has
used the power of the stones to reduce them
to atoms, rendering their mission moot.
In a moment of pure frustration, Thor does
what he should have done during the Battle
of Wakanda and went for the head — killing
the most formidable foe the Avengers had ever
faced roughly 20 minutes into the movie.
It was a shocking narrative decision, one
which Markus and McFeely admitted they struggled
to pin down.
McFeely told the New York Times:
"We always had this problem.
[Thanos] has the ultimate weapon.
He can see [an attack] coming.
It's ridiculous.
[...] At some point, [executive producer]
Trinh Tran went, 'Can't we just kill him?'
And we all went, 'What happens if you just
kill him?
Why would you kill him?
Why would he let you kill him?'"
The answer to that question is simple: Thanos
had accomplished what he set out to do.
Markus explained:
"It reinforced Thanos' agenda.
He was done.
Not to make him too Christ-like, but it was
like,'If I've got to die, I can die now.'"
"And then what?
I finally rest.
And watch the sunrise on a grateful universe."
Thor's brutal beheading of the Mad Titan benefited
no one, however.
It was an act of pure frustration, and one
which was never going to bring back the Infinity
Stones or any of the Avengers' fallen comrades.
In fact, it seems likely that the noble Asgardian's
desperate, vengeful killing of Thanos may
have been the final straw in causing him to
spiral into a years-long bout with depression.
But this also gave Thor, who has gone from
a rather one-note hero to arguably the most
fascinating and complex character in the MCU,
one of Endgame's most emotionally satisfying
arcs.
It wasn't until his encounter with his mother
Frigga in 2013, during the Avengers' time
heist to recover the Infinity Stones, that
he came to terms with his failure.
It all fell into place neatly for Markus and
McFeely, who had gone into the screenwriting
process with little idea of where they could
take the Asgardian's personal journey during
Endgame.
Markus said:
"When we were spitballing for Endgame, we
started with, Thor's on a mission of vengeance.
And then we were like, he was on a mission
of vengeance in the last movie.
This is all this guy ever does!
[...] Let's drive him into a wall and see
what happens."
In the end, by compounding his failure to
stop Thanos in a moment of weakness, the near-immortal
god was made more relatable to the audience
than he had ever been before.
Will Marvel continue exploring the journey
of Odinson in Phase 4 and beyond?
Of all the original Avengers, it makes the
most sense for the God of Thunder's story
to continue and Chris Hemsworth has proven
himself more than capable of taking the character
to more interesting places than anyone ever
expected.
But will he play a key role in Guardians of
the Galaxy Vol. 3, going into action to face
some new cosmic threat?
Will he return for another crossover team-up
film at some point in the MCU's future?
Or will he become the first Avenger to get
a fourth solo flick?
Only time will tell.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.